en vacances je vais partir au brésil à
partir ben c'est pas trop la période du
carnaval bébé a presque mais prévoyez ça
c'est typiquement le mec en bois qui
veut faire le malin je prends au brésil
à le carnaval et non c'est pas cette
période est à vous nous avez ramené une
petite photo oui je vous ai rapporte une
petite photo parce que je fais c'est hot
bas côté je ne sais pas je vous laisse
juge
donc ça c'est ce que vous faites quand
vous allez en vacances mais c'est
beaucoup de sport quand je suis en
vacances j'aime bien les trucs très
sportif très bien approvisionné suffit
et à leur aise lala ne bougez pas je
vois déjà le truc regardes tu postale
hier sur la cuisse oui c'est comme ça ça
fait un peu fait une petite up du pique
nique une photo
oui alors je n'ai envoyé deux je ne sais
pas laquelle a été sélectionné c'est un
copain avec mes frères c'est votre frère
très bien dick te manquer derrière et
trouver des cendres du temps dans le sud
pour pour aider justement mon frère et
ma mère qui viennent d'ouvrir leur bar à
jus 100 % bio 100% vegan hobo provence
[Rires]
vous avez qu à faire de la publicité
vous avez pas un cousin qui vend des
voitures alors la photo de france au
vieux vous pouvez la décrire auparavant
ah bah je suis en lorraine va écouter
orange et moi j'ai pas les moyens de
maxime c'est vrai mais bon les mêmes
photos c'est que j'aurais pu vous dire
on leur a demandé de faire une photo un
peu délire prononcé des vraies photos
comment ça va manger très bien vous avez
pris une photo oui jamais une photo de
vacances c'est une photo entre c'est
très important pour moi c'est entre la
baule et saint nazaire et je passe
régulièrement des vacances là bas et
quand je pars en vacances il faut que je
trouve des pierres donc là je suis sur
ma pierre donc j'ai ma pierre laba
webber heureux
qu'est ce qu'ils avaient sur la pierre
pour vous fassiez vous allez sur une
pierre est pris à une succession de
cette pierre et chaque matin je veux
leur parler
tristesse qu'est ce qu'on leur dit aux
pierres à ça dépend desquels l'année
dernière j'allais encore la dernière
alors il y avait une pierre qui
s'appelait jean luc je crois que c'est
celle là à côté parce que je lui parlais
de jeu disait jean luc fau guest my edge
se passe bien et tout ça je parle aux
gens j'ai retrouvera jean luc chez
lapierre quoi alors là vous avez la
photo mais dix minutes après vous avez
une autre photo avec l'ambulance qui
viennent chercher qu'il le remède on
semble pas ses vacances alors moi j'en
ai une photo justement mais pour me
rappeler un petit peu de bon temps que
du bon temps que je passais en famille à
l'époque où on était tous ensemble avec
mes soeurs avec mes parents voilà c'est
juste peu à l'époque où j'avais un look
de merde
[Applaudissements]
aucun risque et que j'étais en crise
d'ado je me cherchais un peu et c'est un
mobile-home derrière ouais on partait au
camping à saint tropez quand on était
plus jeunes vous avez bien évolué et 1,2
du mobile home à l'elysée par tous s'ils
veulent germa et le dernier c'est parce
que il y à dos et il y un dos on a dû à
la dernière minute quand il nous a
envoyé sa photo l'emmener dans un banc
de montage car monsieur prendre des
photos sur un bateau jusque là ça va je
prends c'est moi expliquait ben c'est
une photo qu'on a prise en otage de deux
caches island et la photo en elle-même
n'est pas intéressante de taux sauf que
après relecture de la photo visiblement
jamais laissé échapper quelque chose de
mon slip est regardée alors le style est
alors c'est pas c'est pas sa vraie télé
comme ça c'est un smiley qu'on a rajouté
mais effectivement elle part alors là
nous ne montrons pas parce que c'est pas
l'esprit de l'émission l'ordre et ce
pour des choses maintenant on est passé
à totalement autre chose c'est un
nouveau thé pmp